In 1980, the historical Medellin Cartel leader,
Pablo Escobar, had an idea.
Basically, he had a vision, a dream: to turn
Colombia into a narco-state; a country where
the government and all public institutions
would be directly controlled by drug trafficking.
Such was his commitment, that in 1982 – as...
I think you all know – Pablo Escobar himself,
one of the most important mobsters in all
of history, gained a seat at the Colombian
chamber of representatives.
And...
it’s important to bear in mind that it’s
one thing for the Mafia to buy or bribe a
politician, and quite another for them to
hold all the power directly.
Can you imagine a country where the police,
the army, all administrative officials and
even the courts themselves were ultimately
under the direct orders of drug-dealers?
Of course, if Pablo Escobar's vision had panned
out, Colombia wouldn’t only have much higher
levels of drug production and export, but
the Medellín Cartel itself would’ve become
untouchable, invincible....
He would’ve gained complete impunity to
do and undo whatever he wanted at will.
Fortunately, Pablo Escobar never managed to
carry out his dream...
However...
today, 3 decades later it looks like his dream
is now being realized; But... this time we
aren’t talking about Colombia, we’re talking
about Venezuela.
Apparently, the four characters you’re looking
at right now…
Don’t only control the country, they are
also the leaders of an international crime
and drug trafficking network.
Of course, we’re talking about:
Nicolás Maduro, President of Venezuela.
Diosdado Cabello the powerful president of
the National Constituent Assembly, whom many
already rank as the strongest man in the regime.
And Tareck El Aissami, former Vice President
and current Minister of Industry and National
Production, whose personal fortune, according
to DEA calculations, surpasses the 3 billion
dollar mark.
3 billion dollars!
And, the fourth, is Néstor Reverol, minister
of Internal Affairs, Justice and Peace, who,
to top it off, was the previous National Counternarcotics
Office Director.
Well, everything indicates that these four
people are leading the transformation of Venezuela
into a narco-state.
Listen up.
THE MAFIA TAKES CONTROL
Venezuela is in shreds.
Hunger is increasing, inflation is out of
control and hundreds of thousands of people
are fleeing the country.
Even hospitals don’t have basic supplies
like medicine, analytical equipment or plasters.
There’s such a huge mess that the PDVSA
itself; the Venezuelan state-owned oil company
with the most reserves in the world, is bankrupt.
Check this out...
To this day, PDVSA has so many embargo orders
that in order to sell the increasingly dwindling
Venezuelan oil, it’s beginning to resort
to tricks and techniques used by Hollywood
movie-style smugglers:
For example, since Venezuelan oil companies
are at risk of being confiscated... to settle
all outstanding debts on the oil they transport...
PDVSA has begun to transfer oil from its ships
to other ships with the Cuban flag out at
sea… who are then responsible for taking
the crude oil to its destination, thus avoiding
being seized.
Because folks, in Venezuela practically everything
that has value, has been or is being looted.
Corruption has reached almost every corner
of the country.
Let's see, the Bolivarian revolution promised
prosperity...
what they forgot to clarify is that all that
prosperity would only be for a few... for
the friends of the revolution, of course.
Don’t believe me?
Well, take a look…
Many regime members promote and lead operations
for gas contraband to sell in Brazil and Colombia.
They are also mostly responsible for food
and medicine contraband, which the state buys
and then sells on the black market.
They have looted public accounts and tens
of billions of dollars have disappeared both
from the government and from PDVSA.
In Venezuela, even the Central Bank’s US
dollars have been looted...
Yes, you heard that right.
Allow me to explain.
One of the first things that the Chavez regime
did was implement a rigid exchange control...
that fixed, for example, the official exchange
between the bolivar and the US dollar, to
a rate that had nothing to do with the numbers
on the street.
That way, the government’s friends could
access US dollars with just a handful of bolivares.
Bolivares that due to the country’s current
hyperinflation are now worth practically nothing.
The maneuver was so well perfected, that it
is estimated that 20% of all imports declared
in recent years have been completely false
operations that were done for the sole purpose
of obtaining dollars at the official exchange
rate, to save them in foreign accounts.
And, this is important, because according
to estimates we could be talking about a theft
of more than 100 billion dollars.
And of course, PDVSA hasn’t escaped this
plunder:
(“A group of companies lent 7.2 billion
bolivares to PDVSA, which, when exchanged
at the black market rate, would be about 42
million dollars, but when exchanged at the
official rate, would become approximately
600 million dollars, which were deposited
in an account in Malta.”
César Batiz, Venezuelan journalist)
But of course...
since no more can be squeezed out of the country,
the regime giants have sought a new alternative
source
of income.
(TURNING INTO A NARCO-STATE)
The issue of drug-dealers and Venezuela isn’t
new...
it has, however, evolved.
Allow me to explain… for years, Colombian
cartels tried to use routes through Venezuela
to distribute their products.
And, of course, to do so, they began bribing
policemen, national guard members, high officials,
etc., etc.
So they’d turn a blind eye.
This was the first stage.
As it worked, dealers got to know the land
better and figured out who they could trust
or not, so they moved into the second stage...
something like: “ok, now that we have a
deal, if I give you more money, you don’t
only look away, you also protect and transport
my merchandise”.
This was the second stage.
Later, many Colombian mobsters realized that
given the enormous pressure they had from
the Colombian government and the DEA, they’d
be safer in Venezuela.
So at the beginning of the 21st century, that’s
precisely what happened, many of these sinister
“merchants” moved their operations center
from Colombia to Venezuela.
And that’s when they started to closely
collaborate with the authorities.
And I mean really closely.
What do you think the Venezuelan government
did then?
In 2005, they decided to expel the DEA from
Venezuelan territory and suspend their agreement
to monitor narco-flights.
Therefore, the Venezuelan territory became
a kind of refuge for drug traffickers, the
United States could no longer keep track of
them.
Fantastic, isn’t it?
Of course, in exchange for getting rid of
the United States, they had to pay a modest
commission – the regime giants needed to
live off of something, right?
That was the third stage.
But... just a moment folks, because that's
how we got to the fourth and last stage, which
is where we’re at right now.
Business was going well... so well that many
of the Bolivarian revolution leaders asked
themselves a question...
We have the government, the police, the army
and a lot of resources...
why on earth should we share anything with
Colombians?
Or whoever?
(“We capture them here, we’ve captured
more than 100 Colombian drug-lords, here in
Venezuela.”)
Do you know what happened then?
Well...
The Venezuelan authorities began arresting
all the drug traffickers who didn’t want
to cooperate with them by giving them their
routes as well as their distribution business…
That’s how people such as Maximiliano Bonilla,
aka “Valenciano”, the chief of the Envigado
Office; Héctor Germán Buitrago, aka “Martin
Llanos”; Diego Perez Henao, aka Diego Rastrojo,
and Daniel Barrera Barrera, aka “el loco”
fell.
All of them were found in the list of the
most significant traffickers.
So everything indicates that right now in
Venezuela, even though there are tons of criminal
groups operating in the area... the government
giants hold the ultimate control...
Characters such as Diosdado Cabello, allegedly
the most important leader of the “Los Soles
Cartel”, the cartel formed by the top leaders
of the Bolivarian government.
(“The Venezuelan people suffer under corrupt
politicians who tighten their grip on power
while lining their own pockets.
“We are imposing costs on figures like Diosdado
Cabello who exploit their official positions
to engage in narcotics trafficking, money
laundering, embezzlement of state funds, and
other corrupt activities".
U.S. Treasury Secretary Steven Mnuchin)
In fact, one of Diosdado Cabello’s own personal
assistants, Leasmy Salazar, fled Venezuela
in 2014 with the help of the DEA.
And his statement couldn't be more forceful:
in addition to providing evidence on the organization’s
operation, he stated that Mr. Diosdado Cabello,
president of the National Constituent Assembly,
gives direct orders on the routes and the
departure of boats loaded with prohibited
substances.
And he’s not the only one.
Testimonies are accumulating in the DEA offices.
For example, there’s Walid Makled’s statement,
from when he was arrested in Colombia in 2011.
Makled was one of the most powerful drug traffickers
in Venezuela.
For example he controlled Puerto Cabello,
which according to the DEA was the exit point
for most of the narcotics distributed from
the country.
Well, after his arrest Makled declared with
great detail that he had done business with
several dozens of Venezuelan generals, high-level
government officials, such as Henry Rangel
Silva... who was later named minister of defense...
or Hugo Carvajal, former army intelligence
director who supposedly paid him $ 50,000
a week...
Quite a nice salary!
He also claimed to have financed one of Hugo
Chavez's campaigns in exchange for concessions
in Puerto Cabello.
With all these relationships, it’s easy
to understand how in November 2016, Efraín
Antonio Campo Flores and Francisco Flores
de Freitas, two of the Venezuelan first lady,
Cilia Flores’s nephews, were convicted in
a New York court for conspiring to traffic
hundreds of kilos of narcotics.
And, folks, according to current estimates,
business in Venezuela won’t stop growing...
Between 15 and 20% of all the cocaine that
moves in the world every year passes through
this country.
And not only that, apparently the number of
laboratories is rising like foam.
Of course...
the giants of the Bolivarian revolution need
money to keep the structures of repression
loyal: the army, the police, the national
guard...
Also, in exchange for working in Venezuela,
the different criminal groups based there,
from the mafia to the paramilitaries and the
Colombian guerrillas, support the regime...
And since there’s good business, Maduro
and company are still filling their pockets.
Unfortunately, the consequences of all this
are terrible:
For one, looting all public resources... has
led the country to ruin; And on top of that,
it’s fueling an enormous amount of violence...
See, according to data from the Venezuelan
Violence Observatory…
in 2017... there were 89 homicides per 100,000
inhabitants in the country.
That is, more than 26,000 people lost their
lives violently.
Venezuela has become the most dangerous country
in all of Latin America... and the situation
in some areas like Caracas is even worse.
The capital’s homicide rate skyrocketed
in 2017 to 130 people per 100,000 inhabitants.
Meanwhile the members of the government who
are taking advantage of this situation and
making actual fortunes are buying properties
all over the world... from the Dominican Republic,
where they are making millionaire investments
in hotels, urbanization, golf courses... to
Madrid,
a city to which not only thousands of Venezuelans
fleeing the disaster are arriving, but also
many of the relatives of the Soles Cartel
bosses and other high position members loyal
to the revolution.
(“I now sometimes find myself sitting in
restaurants in Madrid right next to people
whom I wouldn’t feel comfortable ever seeing
in Caracas,” Leopoldo López Gil, the father
of Leopoldo López, a leading opposition politician
who has been kept under house arrest in Caracas.)
Unfortunately, the Bolivarian regime... has
found its best ally in drug-dealing... both
to fill their pockets and to keep their power.
In short, my friends, that's how things are.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
Thanks for watching!